we're going to make it clear that anyone
collecting unemployment
who is offered a suitable job must
take the job or lose their unemployment
benefits
the president addressing issues
businesses nationwide are facing right
now many have positions to fill
but they're struggling to get candidates
to apply but as orco mana reports some
businesses here in las vegas
are getting creative to entice potential
employees
as our state continues to reopen people
across the valley
are getting back to work but many are
still on unemployment
saying they want jobs that are worth
their while so local businesses are now
offering incentives to make that happen
just like ingredients each play a role
in handcrafted drinks employees are
needed to run local businesses but at
mothership coffee roasters
those have been hard to come by i have
never thought it was possible that we'd
have issues finding staff members
ceo juani romero believes potential
employees are deciding to collect
unemployment benefits instead of getting
jobs amid the kovit 19 pandemic
while bigger companies can afford to
increase pay and give sign up bonuses
romero is offering something different
we focus a lot of our budget towards
mental wellness if they feel like they
need to take a step
back and consider where and how they
want to work
or maybe they need to reduce their hours
or maybe they need to take time off and
then come back
romero says it's working as she's
already hired people
interested in the incentives people are
having to get creative
sonia pedoway connects those in the i.t
field to local jobs
she says many of the companies she works
with are offering professional
development opportunities to entice
workers to come on board
on the job training classes continuing
education that they're able to add to
sweeten the pot to say come work for us
because we're going to invest back in
you
romero says it's all about recognizing
what people want
we just have to really strategize as a
company
to value the things our staff is valuing
it's important to note that deter
is requiring people to prove that
they're looking for jobs
in order to keep getting unemployment
benefits orca mana 8 news now